dark clouds hover over kiss Elam was his
fields but as the farmer suspects they
won't deliver desperately needed rain
three rainy seasons have already come
and gone in South Korea where cassia
when his wife Christine live all they
can find to pick are some legumes
otherwise the entire maize crop their
main income source has dried up the
other time have been harvesting at least
something to keep my family for two to
three months but now I'm a vesting
almost nothing even it won't keep me for
a week seven years ago kisi Liu began a
video project to document the climate
changes in his region he is experienced
a lot of weather extremes including
droughts and floods but it's never been
as bad as it is now instead of being
able to sell his harvest the farmer has
to go to market to buy his maize a
staple in the Kenyan diet the amount he
can actually afford keeps getting
smaller and smaller
is a Pharma I feel neglected because
ever strongly feeding my family but
government it seems not to support us in
the capital Nairobi the so-called corn
crisis has been a source of bitter
controversy for many months maize prices
have skyrocketed by more than 100
percent the problem is that the corn
silos containing the emergency reserves
were depleted soon after the drought
started whether the maize had been
stolen or had rotted away is not clear
and those responsible have yet to
provide a clear answer eventually the
government stepped in importing maize
and launching a subsidy program to bring
prices down but according to a leaked on
satsu the whole system is totally
corrupt the financial expert says both
politicians and business people are
enriching themselves through special
import licenses folks are able to get
access to those licenses and make
seriously big and windfall profits at
the expense of course of the rest of the
country big windfall profits and you
know the theory is that a lot of us
money circulates back into political
spending those very officials bristle at
the corrupt allegations they clean the
government has done its best to counter
the country's food shortages from the
get-go the president declared had
brought a national disaster and he
called upon all the other stakeholders
to join hands and support the government
so anybody who is interested in helping
should join hands and help now but those
people are not interested in helping
they should shut up
not talking everywhere nonsense farmer
Casilla Moussa has long stopped looking
for political solutions instead he and
other farmers are working together to
design homemade irrigation systems for
their fields they still have to work out
the kinks but it's enough to start
growing some tomatoes and there's hope
that this means they'll be able to grow
Mae
again next season